[Applause]
argentines like big celebrations but
they have never done it this way
hundreds of thousands gathered at the
center of the capital Buenos Aires to be
part of a historic day
Argentina winning the biggest prize in
football joy and emotion was everywhere
spectacular this is the biggest Joy
anyone could ask for thank you God thank
you Diego Thank You Messi this children
say it's the best day of their lives and
that now they want to go for a fourth
cup
foreign
people not only took over the streets
but also the bus stops and even the
traffic lights
with exchange rate countries and people
needed to celebrate something well they
have found a perfect excuse to be on the
streets dancing and singing Argentina
has won the World Cup and people here
are promising to celebrate for a very
long time
foreign
walk for hours to be able to get here he
came with his family
that could happen to us is winning even
though Argentina has lots of inflation
and the economy is bad this is filling
our hearts to make us forget everything
thank God we're able to celebrate today
fear now that he has won Argentina's
Third World Cup he will take his place
in this country's history with
argentines thanking him and his team for
years to come
Buenos Aires